what point you're created you moved to
Los Angeles is pretty early so I moved
in 1998 and what I did I have nobody in
the entertainment business I don't know
how to get into the entertainment
business so I went to one of those
modeling things like at the Hilton Hotel
on the weekend you ever hear that on the
radio come you think you got what it
takes
come down to the hill and I see you this
is simple this is this is in Chicago
this Chicago yeah I go down there I get
this beautiful photo they take me they
take a photographer me to the freeway
off-ramp and they put me in some wheat
like a lot of wheat and I'm gonna shoot
nothing says success like an Italian guy
in some way yeah that's so great I
thought so I didn't know anything I'm 20
years old in wheat with a beautiful
sweater no shirt on I have a nice nice
pose and I bring it all my mother's like
my god this is a beautiful photo send it
out to all the casting directors the
late-night talk I sent one to you this
is in 1998 I sent that you sent that
photo to me to you and on the back of it
Photoshop was a bunch of heads and then
the text said Sebastian Maniscalco
coming soon to LA no phone number you
thought people going to get this think
oh we gotta find this guy so when I
arrived three months later I did another
mailing and it said now playing
Sebastian Maniscalco with the phone
number now I'm sure is later I am here
on the couch yeah yeah I took it away
I love you still got the headshot right
I still got I think we have the headshot
I want to see this I love that you're on
a freeway off-ramp there you you should
look like you're in Tuscany or no
Rockford Rockford
you